les origines russes d'anouchka remonte à
ses grands-parents et elles ont
violemment refait surface la semaine
dernière c'est physique ça a été comme
comme s'il y avait une bombe qui avait
explosé dans mois son grand père a
préféré fuir la russie au début du 20e
siècle plutôt que d'être enrôlé dans
l'armée rouge j'ai réalisé que
j'appréhendais cette guerre depuis
tellement longtemps parce qu'un habitait
et même si elle a su se libérer grâce à
l'art du fantôme des ancêtres la guerre
fait remonter le poids la surface ce
poids il ya une culpabilité
c'est ridicule qui en fait la capter à
rien à voir que la conscience même s'il
ne porte lui non plus aucune
responsabilité
sergueï se sentent pas seulement depuis
la semaine dernière depuis il a crime
est ce la honte ce la honte comme ou
début de l'invasion d'un pays de 7,7 une
guerre qui est pas juste voir ce soutien
là c'est difficile c'est honteux et le
soutien dont il parle c'est celui d'une
majorité de russes envers le kremlin
comme même les membres de ma famille à
moscou qui qui répètent la même histoire
de la propagande
c'est tellement ce tellement encore
portable d'en parler parce que je sais
qu'il supporte l'annexion de la crim et
je sais qu'aux portes lier ce
scientifique a quitté la russie après
ses études et il se pose aujourd'hui la
question probablement si je reste je
serai comme heures
la populaire de tellement puissante
il dit que si comprendre ceux qui ne
manifestent pas en russie par crainte de
représailles mais regrette que nombre de
ses anciens concitoyens ne s'informent
pas mieux les gens veulent pas ça n'est
pas ça veut pas savoir
facile pour eux deux
brasset la télé russe et écouter ce
qu'ils disent
et toute cette actualité donne une
résonance troublante un poème canouche
cas avait écrit pour son grand père la
guerre immole la jeunesse folle la state
brûler sa folie est en portait sur le
noir cheval de ton rival pour te cloué à
l'arbre des morts où pleure encore de
vieux remords ici mathieu prost radio
canada montréal